I made sure when I interview with you
they would have some absolutely so Mikey
thank you so much for agreeing to come
on my channel today so that I can
interview interview it's really an honor
why don't you go ahead and reduce
yourself say well you you made the
community really exciting right you you
were really writing at all posting on
Facebook randomly and doing other things
and I got the spider-man scoop a Sony
and Disney are working on a deal to have
five minutes to see you
Wow you got this plate you have the
story of the year and you have no place
to put it and I was friends with the
YouTube show from New York called peace
basement for you and keep the look of
the creator of that YouTube channel is a
huge spider-man so I said you know what
I'm gonna give this to him because you
can do spider-man fans and if you can
use it on his show so I you know
messaged him in the middle of the night
I said hey you know five minutes twigs
of the MCU gave him the whole scoop and
he went on a spaceman and when you build
up to the world and you know at the time
I had Facebook friends I think that was
just start was not the start right there
he was a client of mine turning away and
gave me this information I'm like yeah I
know you're a kind of laughing is my
interest because online with all music
all music orient
my right okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Marvel television was producing the
gifted and we right
[Music]
[Music]
right right I remember that from what I
understand and talked to you
it's still there people can still see
that in the time first the first story
came that you know Tony and that was
that was the big heartbreaking news that
story and I got
[Music]
yeah Sony is gonna try and play this
like you know like marbles fall and so
on and so forth and they're trying to
get the best new deal are possible and
they're going to use the media like this
I mean it's business right so use your
tactics
[Applause]
[Music]
like I guess that was the only voice
saying otherwise everybody you know
can't work things out these are the MCU
and
[Music]
everybody's freaking out right yeah I
remember people finally gave me credit
where the Fox Mar will be like real are
things going right okay yeah no I can't
understand that perfectly yeah because
yeah because I remember that that's when
I first you know someone you're scoops
and then I think I saw it maybe
comicbook.com
said some can and so I remember and I
did a video on it and I was just like
and I did my research cuz I was like
well who is this a guy who's saying this
and then I was like okay well he he
broke original spider-man news in like
2014 I was like [ __ ] clearly he knows
something or someone so clearly there's
some validity here and then there's a
brie Larson thing and didn't you say
something about Benedict Cumberbatch as
well because sorry go ahead
I secretly scoops in two ways I had a
secret group that I was putting this
information out to and no one knew okay
except you know 270 people that were in
that group and it was a private secret
group I mean I had no intention of
finding fame or fortune from this it was
a fun thing to do you're just being a
fin they said you know what do you wanna
do this under a secret identity
and so for a couple of years I was
called the shadow on these days they're
interesting yeah and I was scooping all
these stories through them under the
alias and it wasn't until after the
spider-man deals with the most recent
one where I actually they outed me on
the show and they made up data update
ulala's they're like hey this this guy
who's famous no he's actually been doing
this for years and are so as the shadow
he is this an expose it got scooped
we're seeing the doors closed
[Music]
spider-verse by the MCU yeah I remember
all of it all yeah it was crazy like
saying no it's you know bad at all I
mean they're just trying to go look that
way and sure
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that's that's what that's what we
love that's why I originally started my
channel I know I talk a lot about Marvel
but I mean I'm a really a true nerd all
around right I love everything
yeah and I think most people do but you
and I have talked you've told me a
little bit about your backstory not a
lot of people know your backstory why
don't you go ahead and tell us how you
first got started I know you were you
were first published professional in
1987 right yeah
in California called special edition and
they had episodes with Stanley and I
never heard the guy was that reading
kind books at all at the time and I was
really captivated by what I saw because
they had footage from the hall cartoons
every guy I've never seen before
spider-man cartoons and then images of
comic books they showed qianxi is like
what an Asian got like Agent P hero and
I was telling my my Ben brother-in-law
about it because he were watching the
show and he said you know you want to
get in the car looks like I can get you
in the car so yeah
the very next day he goes to Toys R Us
with Toys R Us to the rest but he bought
me a book called the origins of Marvel
Comics oh cool and so my first kind
books I've ever read were the first
appearance of the Spider Man Doctor
Strange testing for or into history like
right in the beginning you know and so I
remember reading that I like manga is
not yeah about nine years old and I just
mesmerized and that book also has the
Silver Surfer hmm just really cool
looking characters and a year before
this I saw Star Wars the first one
opening day and I was so lucky because
Sacramento was one of the few cities
that had Star Wars nothing day yeah yeah
so immediately I got I got into it and
fast forward 87 I was in the Philippines
my own country I returned home you know
when I was he was amazing yeah Wow Wow
so even you've been really in it for a
long time wow that's a lot numerous
awards I won the Western Association of
yeah since 1918 yeah you've been in a
while that's one of the reasons I wanted
to interview everybody because clearly
you have a very real structured company
but they're also very spontaneous we'll
take a look at last night scott
derrickson yeah and it's it's it's
probably the most anticipated movie
coming up and the director quits and
it's like whoa
insane but just for the back to point
I know people out there saying okay we
saw it coming yes easiest favor 20/20
hindsight right there is some discussion
about this thing about the release date
I mean rent and that I think everybody
interprets that as I really want it to
be a horror film like a true scary
horror film and Kevin Feige is like nope
it's gonna be pg-13 and we're not gonna
scare little kids and upon the personal
and yeah obviously increase the word
elements of the previous but what
Kenneth buggy wanted and what he has to
do is to move the MCU as a whole forward
right okay and so this is more of a
transitional film and then it's going to
open the gate to new storylines and and
other eventually MCU where as direction
where to focus more on the HP Lovecraft
Steve Ditko elements of the franchise
that's tiny the one division right
direction had no problems with except
that you know this movie is becoming
larger in scope and more super
then initially planned and I think
that's where the breakdown occurred it's
gonna be more linked to the MCU but more
MCU heavy in terms of its references and
where it's headed gotcha
well and when you have it when you have
a title called multiverse of madness I
mean the multiverses we could there's so
much potential there I feel like like
you share with other kind of gateways
and other many other defines you stories
[Music]
it sounds like he wanted to make his own
movie but Kevin was saying you know it's
really a movie for other movies as well
[Music]
[Music]
yeah Bob I yeah I think Bob Iger said
that
I think Derrickson lawyer the more
simple film and I can understand that as
a director yeah especially when you had
the first one to yourself right and now
it's the sequel so I can definitely
understand that in fact you know I did a
video about it last night and my
speculation was I think I literally said
Scott Derrickson wanted to just focus on
his film his aspects to picking off for
the last one we know he's he want a
nightmare he want a nightmare in the
first one but there's just with
everything happening into you and the
world the MC world got bigger cuz hello
the Fox deal we have so many new
characters and Kevin Feige is already
confirm they have plans for them he said
it at SDCC
we didn't even have time to talk about
mutants and Fantastic Four clearly
there's already plans for them and
clearly you've already leaked the
Illuminati so it does sound like exactly
what you said you know Scott Derrickson
one of this film yeah that's that's the
MCU is huge and you know they mark
Marvel started this this connected world
right oh right yeah I do
[Music]
independent filmmaker and you know he
easily you know can can do it other
filmmakers I think have such a a tight
vision that it's difficult for them to
open it up yeah and I think that just
comes with you know who the director is
yeah yeah yeah I think some I think
personally think some would be really
fascinated and honored with jumping into
the MCU and contributing to the universe
but I mean Scott Derrickson Exorcism of
Emily Rose sinister right like big scary
films yeah and he's really a creative
person and just wanted to focus on
creating a specific movie and it was
just a little bit bigger than that which
as we've heard creative differences they
had the part ways which is
understandable well I guess how do you
because a lot of people you know it's
like okay so vendors in games here was
the biggest movie of all time you took
you know 10 11 years to build it up what
do you do now and it's just kind of like
well I guess you do multiverse madness
now we've been yes
over and over again yeah and then years
for the deal to even happen character
[Music]
changes are being made
[Music]
I like dr. strange yeah and and I think
since that's happened there's been
plenty of articles out there and plenty
of talk online of course as it always
happens is that Marvel actually has a
pretty clear direction on what's going
to happen Yeah right
Kevin Feige is come out and said we're
gonna introduce characters that we've
wanted to introduce
and people aren't expecting well no
one's expecting a little not hey maybe
now since you leaked it but I mean
that's clearly what's happening
[Music]
yeah that'd be crazy I want them to hire
Zack Snyder almost and that makes
perfect sense because they because we
already know that wand is gonna be in
Doctor Strange movers Amanda's we know
that they're going to definitely tie
into each other I mean that's already
it's already been stated I think Matt
Jackman that's his name I think Matt
Chapman would probably be really good
choice to do that since he's directing
the one business well let's talk about
the ultimate joke
Martin Scorsese comes in and maybe he
can make it cinema then right because he
says it's not cinema maybe he can
finally make the MC set of mother
clearly struggling with the biggest
movie of all time recently yeah exactly
now he's a joke mark Scorsese a great
director he has his own opinion yeah of
course of course yeah I believe he
directed which is one of my favorite my
favorite movie so much oh yeah oh yeah
exactly so it's definitely different
time now since when they were you know
directing all these big films
I'm gonna go to a see here to see a
movie then it has to be some that I feel
need to be seen on a lot of large screen
I know otherwise my god
yeah exactly yeah now I agree of course
yeah of course so Star Wars you know
mark mark
all the marbles with everything you know
the goodies that just like you said they
make you want to see them the very
opening night yeah exactly
you know and it's more convenient for
Netflix so I appreciate you coming on
appreciate you giving us back story have
you heard anything going on lately you
know I have to ask so I am hearing we're
going to character might be possibly
being loved and thunder but I'm I'm
thinking that she's not maybe a cameo
possibly but I'm hearing that first
sister is coming to the big screen
really Angela Wow I don't know what our
project
show me Minnie her debut it it sings to
me
the character is perfect for Disney
plush show hmm interest that's really
interested in because so all drift I
think that's her name Odie's daughter
right but said the you know the Norse
way Odin's daughter she so in the comic
she's supposed to be the first very
curious to see that's very interesting
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah cuz yeah because it seems like they
they almost have done the story with
hella so I'm I'm curious as well well
well thank you for telling us that
that's that's very I thought you're
gonna stay in chances for a second but
that's that's kind of more interesting
than chant wrist well thank you for
sharing that with us I definitely
appreciate me yeah my channel
transformers I love it right okay so
completely new
Wow really crossover Wow well so that
kind of makes sense because wasn't there
a recent something with Hasbro yeah
[Music]
right okay that's what it is right wow
that would be insane yeah I think that
would be a good way I loved Hailee
Steinfeld in the last bumblebee film and
you know a lot of people didn't really
like the last Power Rangers they didn't
really like it that much I know a lot of
people did but I but they're also almost
50/50 yeah I mean it'd be really hard to
fail all they do it's not but they make
it look easy I mean I was just talking
about DC the other day about that as
well how they should probably just do
their single one-off films and then they
can make Wonder Woman and Batman and
them come together but not everything
has to be in one combined universe
because like you said my eye makes it
look easy but it's not that easy
yeah well thanks for right will it
actually happen yeah so it's a little
bit unsure yeah so then if you don't
mind I will ask and obviously say as
little or none as you want but for
people wondering how exactly do you do
you happen upon these scoops
I've been in business for 33 years now
and you know I met people you know in
the 90s
ended up working with some pretty
important job sure right now that you
tell people people got to give the mouth
shots right that's it okay well it's
huge now yeah it's it's been I can
imagine for you spend quite a ride
because you did really kind of just blow
up after that it's been awesome to see
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't really hear anymore of course
you have they have two of course right
exactly yeah they can't they can't be
given information they just have I know
that Kevin Feige zoom and ooh well I
know my I know at least my subscribers
and the people who watch my channel are
more than happy with the marble yeah
it's a great community we love the
league so want to thank you for
everything
Nona thank you for what you've done for
a community I'm sure I speak for a lot
of people and we say that we truly do
enjoy the leaks and what you do for
everybody thank you for your for coming
on today
I appreciate that all right well thank
you so much we got to 2 scoops today and
we'll be talking soon so thank you